jeff bezos just came out saying he's
planning on buying cnn what are your
thoughts if jeff bezos now owns
washington post and ends up buying and
owning cnn what happens to media
i don't know cnn has been so badly
left-wing zucker's done such a terribly
one-sided hatchet job um that probably
can't get a whole lot worse without
losing
all of its viewers so it depends on what
basis wants to do i've been very
disappointed that bezos has not
imposed more order on the washington
post and the washington post
used to be a serious newspaper right now
it's a left-wing propaganda
right and that's really tragic you know
if you'd had
the scale of scandal that the biden
family has
uh in the 1970s imagine when when
woodward and bernstein went to see
bradley the
managing editor and said you know we
want to dig into this watergate thing
and he said nah skip it let's not bother
nixon
it's inconceivable yet we have all sorts
of evidence eyewitnesses
laptop computer data that
the biden family not hunter biden the
biden family
has been engaged in absolute corruption
uh and the new york times the washington
post all these places cnn
all of them have hidden it because
they're trying to protect the bunny in
the basement
uh and i think that uh you know it'll be
interesting and i'm very sad
that bezos has not insisted on some
level of
professionalism at the washington post